mieux comprendre cette annonce de la
Réserve fédérale américaine Fred Demers
est avec nous il est directeur général
solutions d'investissement multi-actif
chez BMO gestion mondiale d'actifs merci
beaucoup d'être là Monsieur merci donc
75 points de base c'était assez attendu
cette hausse du taux directeur est-ce
que c'est la bonne décision où on aurait
pu pousser un peu plus comme certains
l'attendais le risque était sans point
de base on a éliminé ça mais quand même
il y a encore beaucoup de travail à
faire et puis c'est là que ça ça fait
mal si on pense que le taux directeur
présentement on pense 4 et demi mais à
mon avis le risque est toujours de se
diriger vers le la barrière du 5% et
franchir ça c'est vraiment là où on
entre dans la zone de la mort en
alpinisme où il y a plus d'air où
l'économie vraiment ça risque de d'une
récession la grêle la gravité de la
récession reste difficile le marché de
l'emploi est extrêmement solide donc
c'est ça qui surprend à date mais quand
même on va mettre beaucoup de stress
éventuellement mais là vous me dites 5 %
lorsque dit la Fed aujourd'hui c'est le
taux directeur pourrait aussi autour de
4,4 c'est ce qu'on dit à la fin de
l'année 5 intéressant est-ce que c'est
sur le radar même si ce n'est pas
officiel selon vous absolument parce que
faut pas oublier qu'il y a quelques mois
déjà leur vue était pas ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui donc une approche très
graduelle dans la révision de leur
analyse les chiffres évidemment de
l'inflation nous ont surpris mais quand
même le travail qui reste à faire que
l'inflation était à 8 ou 5 %, faut
resserrer et puis donc à mon avis on
continue sous-estimer
les risques à la hausse sur les taux
d'intérêt donc sans quand même ça risque
d'être un niveau assez difficile à
franchir point possible et difficile bon
j'imagine que vous faites peur peut-être
certaines personnes à la maison reste à
voir si ça va se concrétiser est-ce que
est-ce que cela dit on a besoin de se
rendre à ce niveau-là pour freiner la
consommation pour freiner l'intérêt on a
déjà certains signes de ralentissement
aux États-Unis est-ce qu'il faut pousser
la note encore plus je pense que il y a
un sentiment de panique dans les banques
centrales pas juste à la fête dans le
port des banques centrales donc on agit
très vite donc le risque c'est comme
conduire le risque d'un accident
augmente à mesure qu'on convaincre donc
c'est ça devient un peu corset encore
une fois sans voir de signe on voit à
peine des signes de ralentissement dans
la création de l'emploi aux États-Unis
puis à mon avis c'est la variable la
plus importante pour déterminer si on va
franchir facilement le cap des 4% et
même approcher 5 la question qui se pose
c'est quand on appuie sur le frein pour
reprendre votre métaphore de la voiture
quand on a pris sur le frein si
rapidement
bon le risque est de plonger l'économie
en récession Jérôme Paol aujourd'hui à
la fête dit ce n'est pas officiellement
dans le scénario on prévoit encore une
croissance très faible mais au
rendez-vous pourquoi on n'ose pas dire
qu'on se dirige alors dans une récession
les économistes de façon générale et les
banques centrales en particulier aiment
pas prévoir les récessions donc on dit
souvent il y a un grand délai la
récession 2008 qui a commencé en
décembre 2007 a été annoncé en décembre
2008 donc ça a pris presque un an les
gens regardent les indicateurs le
faitaient qu'il y a beaucoup
d'incertitudes et puis je pense qu'on va
continuer à débattre mais la trajectoire
me semble évidente on va avoir un niveau
de croissance négatif donc on va pouvoir
parler de rester encore une fois c'est
la gravité qui est important et puis une
récession souvent je pense que ce qui
différencie une récession plus sévère
d'une moindre c'est vraiment ce qui se
passe au niveau de l'emploi et c'est ça
qui va un effet sur les entreprises sur
le crédit et la performance en général
donc celle qui est à venir parce que
j'entendais d'ailleurs un de vos
collègues Davis un petit peu plus tôt
aujourd'hui chez BMO dire c'est
99,99 % la probabilité d'une récession
et les banquiers centraux veulent une
récession et ce qui est-ce qu'il faut
passer par là pour remettre l'économie
sur des bases solides si on veut je
pense que ce qu'on veut éviter c'est une
deuxième vague d'inflation il y a des il
y a des risques qui sont pas à ignorer
donc on veut s'assurer avec une
récession on limite le risque une
deuxième vague parce que s'il y a une
deuxième vague là ça devient de plus en
plus dur et c'est ça qu'on a vu dans les
années 110 c'est pour ça que que power
parle énormément de la période des
années 110 parce qu'on a eu des vagues
successives d'inflation et donc
récession qui s'en vient mais je sentais
vous alliez me dire que la sévérité de
la chose on pourrait s'en sortir ce sera
pas nécessairement une catastrophe mais
plutôt un glissement vers une récession
le glissement ça c'est important en 2020
avec le pandémie c'était vraiment le
précipice mais là c'est une récession
beaucoup plus traditionnelle on le
resserrement monétaire où il y a des
excès on a de l'inflation mais les
pénuries de main d'oeuvre je pense qu'on
va rejoindre un grand rôle à diminuer
l'impact sur le marché de l'emploi donc
oui peut-être le taux de chômage
augmente de 1 2 points pourcentage mais
pas trois quatre cinq points pourcentage
comme l'avait vu en 2008 et ça c'est une
grosse différence dans l'environnement
économique évidemment les marchés les
investisseurs retiennent leurs souffles
quand on a des annonces comme celle-là
des annonces sur le futur des taux
d'intérêt qu'est-ce que ça signifie par
exemple pour les marchés en termes
d'inquiétude pour les investisseurs ce
qui a été annoncé aujourd'hui mais deux
choses c'est que le vent qui nous amène
justement à penser que le 5% est un
risque de plus en plus important va
continuer de s'intensifier va dépendre
de la performance des données
macroéconomiques l'emploi en particulier
mais aussi
bénéfice des entreprises qui va partir à
la baisse les attentes sont encore très
très roses on commence à peine à réviser
à la baisse les attentes de bénéfice des
grandes sociétés américaines faut
s'attendre un minimum une 10% de
contractions du bénéfice qui est encore
une fois par rapport à une récession
normale c'est 20-25 %. donc quand on dit
10 % c'est quand même un scénario pas
optimiste mais qui est quand même plus
jovial par rapport à un environnement de
récession s'additionnerait donc au recul
qu'on a déjà connu depuis le début de
l'année parce que souvent les marchés
anticipent ce qui est incorporé dans la
valeur des indices c'est déjà ce qui va
se produire dans l'avenir donc ce que
vous me dites c'est qu'il pourrait y en
avoir encore plus de ce recueil je pense
qu'on a vu à date cette année c'est
essentiellement l'effet du Roseman est
taux d'intérêt donc il paye sur la
valorisation
des titres des sociétés donc on n'a pas
vraiment en termes de performance c'est
bénéfices ont été très bons la dernière
saison excellente les attentes
commencent à peine à être réviser à la
baisse on commence à peine à incorporer
des scénarios de récession jusqu'à là je
pense que les gens étaient confortables
de dire mais c'est un scénario de risque
et un scénario de base bon on va essayer
de retenir les éléments optimistes de ce
que vous venez de nous dire monsieur
Demers d'autant plus que le dollar
canadien pourrait en prendre sur pour
son rhume avec le différentiel entre les
taux d'intérêt entre les États-Unis le
Canada on retient tout ça et on essaie
d'être positif merci beaucoup monsieur
de merde d'avoir été là